foreign
[Music]
Spencer here for Jihad watch a program
of the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
for the center for security policy
Arthur Wagner a member of the
alternative for Germany afd party that
opposes Angela merkel's suicidal influx
of Muslim migrants recently gained
headlines as well as crowing and
accolades from all the usual
infiltrators saboteurs and Demis by
converting to Islam
but then he revealed why he had answered
the call of Allah it was he said all
about the Christian Church's moral
decline one of the reasons Wagner
explained is tied to changes that have
taken place in the church which no
longer reflects my values he said that
it was unacceptable for Christian
leaders to support marriage for all and
to participate in gay pride parades
where our children
excoriating the Protestant Church's
moral decline is one thing but now
Wagner has joined a religion that
teaches that homosexuals must be put to
death the Quran contains numerous
condemnations of homosexual activity and
lot when he said to his people do you
commit such immorality as no one has
preceded you with from among the worlds
indeed you approach men with desire
instead of women rather you are a
transgressing people and we reigned upon
them A Reign of stones then see how was
the end of the criminals that's the
Quran chapter 7 verses 80 through 84.
Muhammad specifies the punishment for
this in a Hadith the messenger of Allah
said whoever you find doing the action
of the people of lot execute the one who
does it and the one to whom it is done
that's from the Hadith collection known
as tsunan Abu dawood number 4462.
now moral decline on the one hand or
moral myopia on the other giving a
Divine sanction to murder Wagner has
chosen the moral myopia Muslims and
non-muslims often tell us that Muslims
hate the West for its decadence its
immorality its lasciviousness which they
contrast unfavorably with the supposed
morality and uprightness of the Islamic
world
often this boils down to a Muslim
critique of Western Freedom as Wagner
offers as a reason for his conversion
in line with that the Mufti of Australia
once complained that Australian law
guarantees freedoms up to a crazy level
yet genuine freedom is an indispensable
prerequisite for any cultivation of real
virtue even today's ruthless and
Confused West that has to such a great
degree cast off judeo-christian values
makes it more possible to be virtuous
than the Apparently much more
straight-laced Islamic world with its
stonings amputations death penalties for
an array of offenses including apostasy
Islam has created not a framework in
which people can become genuinely good
but an Empire of fear
in the Empire of fear people don't dare
step out of line not out of an authentic
understanding that the path of moral and
ethical uprightness is preferable to the
alternative much less out of love for
God but because they are afraid of what
would happen to them if they did depart
from Islam's vision of morality were
people unable to choose to do evil their
choosing of the good is merely a
manifestation of fear and of the power
of coercion those who have no choice but
to be good demonstrate nothing about
whether their beliefs enable or Inspire
them to choose the good when they could
just as easily not do so
this explodes Islam's moral critique of
the West Islam envisions people behaving
in a virtuous manner only because
they're too afraid to do otherwise
Iran's Ayatollah Khomeini once thundered
whatever good there is exists thanks to
the sword and in the shadow of the sword
people cannot be made obedient except
with the sword the sword is the key to
Paradise which can be opened only for
the holy Warriors
the use of fear is a motivating factor
which Arthur Wagner has now chosen in
his outrage over the West's moral
decline is not anything but the worst
moral decline of all it also highlights
how radically different Islamic law is
from the core values and principles of
American society however since war is
deceit as Muhammad said the Islamic
propaganda machine with the Willing help
of the establishment media will continue
to obscure these vital truths for most
Americans nonetheless as Islam continues
to expand its presence in the U.S the
horrors of sharia and the Empire of fear
it creates will eventually become
obvious here although probably only when
it is too late just as it is already too
late for Arthur Wagner I'm Robert
Spencer
[Music]